what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and something insanely cool has happened
for the fans of Keanu Reeves who want
him in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
somehow in some way shape or form there
is actually a possibility that you could
be getting your wish and I'm one of
those people as well I really want to
see Keanu Reeves in the MCU I think
there are a ton of great roles that he
could play and personally I am myself on
the Ghost Rider train I would love for
Keanu Reeves to come into the MCU and
play Johnny Blaze he would crush that
role however right now Keanu Reeves is
going around and he's doing a lot of
press junkets and interviews for John
Wick 4. so a lot of people have been
asking him about a bunch of different
possibilities mostly revolving around
the film however Keanu Reeves recently
did an ask me anything on Reddit and it
was 100 him it was through Lion's gate
which is the studio behind the movie so
it's 100 legit and one of his answers to
a certain question was Marvel related
shout out to the user
kylie2133 for asking the question to
Keanu Reeves has there ever been a role
in your career that you regret turning
down and here's what Keanu Reeves had to
say in reply to that dot dot dot no dot
dot dot but I did always want to play
Wolverine now this statement alone right
here is enough to excite any normal
Marvel fan in fact even if you're not a
big Marvel fan even if you're just a
casual moviegoer you definitely know who
Keanu Reeves is and you definitely know
who Wolverine is and you'd probably
still love to see Keanu Reeves play
Wolverine now of course this is super
exciting but the real big question after
this is is this actually possible
because sure it's awesome that Keanu
Reeves said that he always wanted to
play Wolverine but that doesn't mean
he's going to so the question is can he
actually do that is that actually a
possibility with Marvel Studios with
Kevin feige the president of Marvel
Studios want that well the cool news is
is yes this is an actual possibility
because it has been confirmed before
that Kevin feige has met with Keanu
Reeves now for those of you who may not
know Marvel Studios and Kevin feige meet
with a lot of different actors they meet
a lot of different actors frequently and
they meet with them several times and
the whole point of this is to find a
role that they would be perfect for it's
not always bringing them in to say hey
we think you would be perfect for this
role sometimes it's hey we want you to
be a part of the MCU it would be great
if you could let's brainstorm together
about certain characters that you think
and we think would be a perfect fit for
you you could play the perfect character
they do that quite frequently and Kevin
feige has confirmed this and Jake
Gyllenhaal confirmed this as well when
he was cast as Mysterio he said that he
had been meeting with Marvel Studios for
years until finally the character
Mysterio popped up and both Marvel
Studios and Jake Gyllenhaal said that's
it that's the role so right now we are
hoping that's what the deal is with
Keanu Reeves Keanu Reeves has met with
Kevin feige and since we haven't really
heard any rumors or reports that he has
actually been cast as a role we can
assume they are looking for a role for
him to have in the MCU so if the big
question right now is could Keanu Reeves
actually play Wolverine in the MCU the
answer is yes yes it is an actual
possibility now will it actually happen
that's a whole different question
because I would love for Keanu Reeves to
play Wolverine however a lot of people
are going to say he's kind of too old
for the role right now we know the X-Men
are going to be in the MCU pretty soon
probably starting in Phase 7 but we also
know that they're going to be sticking
around for a very long time probably
forever or at least as long as the MCU
is still a thing which I actually do
believe will be pretty close to forever
so as I've said before when talking
about the new X-Men characters that are
going to come into the MCU and the
actors that are going to play them larva
Studios is looking for actors that they
can have play one character for the next
10 to 15 years really all you have to do
is think about Robert Downey Jr and Iron
Man Iron Man came out in 2008 which
means Robert Downey Jr was working with
Marvel Studios before the
2007-2006. he played Iron Man all the
way till Avengers endgame which came out
in 2019 so his career was from about
2007 to 2019 with Marvel Studios that's
11 years and that's what Marvel Studios
is going to want heck the same goes for
Thor if not even a little bit more for
Chris Hemsworth because we got Thor in
2011 and we still have Thor in the MCU
till this day and he's even stated that
there is probably going to be another
Thor movie with a different tone he
specified but we know that he's going to
show up in Avengers Kang Dynasty and
most likely Secret Wars as well so he's
gonna be with the MCU even longer than
Robert Downey Jr was but this is what
Marvel Studios wants so could Keanu
Reeves play Wolverine in the MCU for the
next 10 to 15 years the answer is
probably but do they want somebody as
old as he is and he's really not even
that old but would they want somebody
younger to play Wolverine so at the end
of that career at the end of that 10 11
12 15 years whatever it is the character
isn't really that old and the answer to
that is probably that's probably what
Marvel Studios want somebody younger
however that doesn't mean that Keanu
Reeves couldn't play a version of
Wolverine in fact if there is any right
time for him to be a Wolverine in the
MCU now is the time because we are
literally in the Multiverse Saga there
are infinite amounts of Kang variants
and there are infinite amounts really of
any variants out there Deadpool is
already bringing Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine back into action and he's
going to be bringing him into the MCU
and there are rumors and reports stating
that he is going to show up in secret
Wars as well along with a lot of other
original X-Men and Secret Wars so that's
the perfect opportunity for Keanu Reeves
to play Wolverine he could play a
variant of Wolverine in the MCU in
secret Wars or maybe even Deadpool maybe
even make it funny because Hugh Jackman
has recently said that there are going
to be multiple Wolverine variants in
Deadpool 3 3. he specifically said that
he is going to be playing different
variants of Wolverine but that doesn't
mean that they can't bring in another
Wolverine that looks different that
could be Keanu Reeves and it could
probably work out very well because
Deadpool breaks the fourth wall he could
say something like oh look it's a Keanu
Reeves variant of Wolverine Keanu Reeves
could even make a joke and say finally
I've always wanted to play Wolverine and
then he could die for the sake of Comedy
I can see Ryan Reynolds Deadpool killing
him but since Hugh Jackman did say that
there are going to be multiple variants
of Wolverine that means it is possible
that Keanu Reeves could show up there as
well since he's met with Marvel Studios
he has probably told Kevin feige hey I
always wanted to play Wolverine in Kevin
feige as we already know is not really
against fan service if it's done the
right way Marvel Studios already told us
for Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness that Kevin feige thought it
would be really fun to cast John
Krasinski as Mr Fantastic in Another
Universe because of all of the fan
castings so Kevin feige sees all of
these fan casting he hears all about it
and he's not against fan service so
again if he can do it the right way so
Deadpool 3 and Secret Wars and really
any movie moving forward in the
Multiverse Saga could have the potential
to bring in a different variant of
Wolverine however again I do think it
would be so funny if Keanu Reeves popped
up as a wolverine variant in Deadpool 3.
and if this gets around about Keanu
Reeves wanting to play Wolverine heck
they have not started filming yet they
could totally add this in just as a
funny moment in the film and to have
Keanu Reeves fulfill his dream of
wanting to play Wolverine now again just
to confirm Kevin feige has met with
Keanu Reeves about roles for him in the
MCU and I do think he would make a
perfect Johnny Blaze I would love to see
him as Ghost Rider I think that is the
role for him there have been rumors
going around that Ghost Rider is going
to be entering the MCU relatively soon
let's hope that is real we do know the
supernatural side of the MCU has begun
and we even did get a little teaser of a
Donnie Blaze and She-Hulk although I
doubt that really means anything but
since Kiana was meant of Marvel Studios
hopefully it could be about Ghost Rider
and again hopefully it could be about
having a cameo as a variant of Wolverine
but hey let me know your thoughts about
all of this in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news don't forget to
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf